the jurogan experience this is coming
out next week for people listening
today's november 19th the written house
um verdict was read today
and uh surprisingly no riots right no
riots yet
well it's early a it's early
and b it's a bummer it's not a good call
to to
make that call make that verdict release
on friday afternoon because now you got
a bunch of people sitting around on the
weekend going what are we going to do i
think to their credit there have been a
lot of left-wing people that have
actually read the transcripts and
actually paid attention to the true
story instead of just the media
narrative and there's a lot of people
like anna kasparian and glenn
greenwald's been on top of it from the
beginning but a lot of people have
gotten the word out that the version of
the story that most people are just
spouting out the headline version
without reading this the the actual meat
of the story itself is not accurate at
all his kid's not a white supremacist by
any stretch of the imagination he was
kind of playing cop kind of playing emt
and he was going he was [ __ ] 17.
going there and he did apparently
provide aid and help a bunch of people
and at multiple occasions was chased and
pulled the rifle out and when they
retreated he didn't shoot it was only
when he was attacked he was hit with a
skateboard someone pulled a gun on him
that's when he shot people i mean it was
all
very reasonable
maybe not reasonable that a 17 year old
shows up with a [ __ ] gun to riots but
in his mind this is where his family's
from and apparently he wanted to help
but their version of it that they were
selling to the media and the [ __ ]
president said it that he's a white
supremacist jen saki recently said the
president does not contr condone
vigilantism that kid was in no way shape
or form a vigilante he was not a
vigilante he was armed but he was
protecting himself and it turned out
that that actually he needed it they
actually chased him down whether they
chased him down because he had a gun i
don't [ __ ] know but they definitely
were [ __ ] chasing him they definitely
hit him with a skateboard they
definitely knocked him to the ground
so
maybe enough of the actual story got out
where it doesn't seem like a thing to
riot for because a lot of people also
thought he shot black people
they thought he went down there when
people found out it was white people and
then when they found out it was [ __ ]
pedophiles that this guy was a straight
up one of the guys he shot straight up
[ __ ] pedophile child rapist just
terrible person the other guy rap sheet
big old rap sheet one guy a bunch of his
[ __ ] [ __ ] was exonerated six days
before the trial like what are you doing
so maybe all that information got out to
the point where people are hey guys this
is not the hill to die on this ain't the
one i certainly like your positive
attitude about this i was i was actually
checking out twitter before i rolled in
here and there are people that are going
completely insane right now and
the the the narrative that you just put
out
they don't didn't hear any of it they
only heard the other narrative which is
that this guy you know what what's the
lot there's certain there's certain
parts of the line here you know this guy
was
had an illegal gun
traveled across state lines
and shot and murdered
two people
who were there to protect and support
black lives that that's that's what
that's what a lot of people are saying
right now yeah so i would love it if joe
rogan is right right now and that people
are going hey you know what let's let's
get a little bit more nuanced let's
study this
here's the thing though those people on
twitter how many of those people are
real people
how many of those [ __ ] people aren't
trolls but look a lot of them might be
trolls a lot of them are trolls okay a
lot of them are trolls but there's also
real people in there and there's people
that get swayed by this stuff and and
when you you know look
don't you talk to some people sometimes
that you realize they are watching a
different movie than you 100
and
and it's almost like
you're the crazy one oh yeah you're
sitting there going like everything you
just rattled off about kyle rittenhouse
there are people that i know and
probably people that you know too
that are absolutely think everything you
just said is the most insane right-wing
alt-right freaking
load of
white power propaganda that they've ever
heard in their life i have to meet with
some tonight i think i think my wife's
friends yeah tonight when i'm after
after i leave here i'm gonna have to
have drinks with my wife and her friends
and i have a feeling
that i'm gonna have to go well
that's not real and this is actually i'm
happy to show my phone a bunch of times
pass it around and and they're gonna
look at you like here's what sucks about
social media too is the chances of you
the chance of you convincing maybe some
of your wife's friends tonight maybe you
have an okay chance of maybe a little
bit depending on how dug in they are
the chances of someone
on social media convincing someone else
that that oh you know what i see your
point thanks for pointing it out it's
almost there it's almost zero it's
almost zero does anybody ever [ __ ]
say oh you're right
social media it never happens yeah
pointless it even says that no never
says you know what good call yeah i
actually i see what you're i see where
you're coming from yeah no one says that
at all
you